TATIANA SUAREZ: I believe that
I'm the best in the world.
COMMENTATOR:
Such a dominant figure.
COMMENTATOR 2:
Suarez is on another level.
COMMENTATOR:
I haven't seen this kind
of dominance in a long time.
SPEAKER: One of the great
what-ifs in MMA history.
We all thought, like,
she's gonna be a champion.
SPEAKER 2: The former
wrestling prodigy returns
after a nearly four-year layoff.
SPEAKER 3: What's your name?
Tatiana Suarez.
♪ (INSPIRATIONAL MUSIC
PLAYING) ♪
TATIANA: My entire life,
people told me that
I shouldn't wrestle
because I was a girl,
I shouldn't be there
'cause I was a girl.
SPEAKER 4: Come on, Tatiana!
She just... (MIMICS HITTING MAT)
...put these kids to their back.
Tatiana Suarez
is one of the pioneers,
I would say,
of female wrestling.
That was just kind of
the biggest eye-opener.
Like, wow, this is really
something that I could do.
SPEAKER 2: At one point,
a US Olympic hopeful
in wrestling,
those plans were derailed
with a serious injury
which revealed something
much larger than that.
It ended up being cancerous.
She kinda...
went into the dark.
SPEAKER 5: Over the years,
you've had a variety
of injuries.
SPEAKER: It's a real travesty.
DANA WHITE: You break your neck,
you get thyroid cancer,
then you blow
your entire knee out.
Life has thrown a lot at her.
TATIANA: I don't think
I've ever thought about
giving up on anything,
but I really felt it.
I knew that I wasn't done.
I'm gonna find a way
to fight again.
The things
we asked Tatiana to do,
I don't know many athletes
who could've endured it.
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
TATIANA: I was off
for a very long time.
You just think to yourself,
like,
"Will I be the same athlete?"
At this time,
you would be cleared to compete.
DANA:
She's worked her whole life
to get here,
and she's overcome it all.
COMMENTATOR 3: Tatiana Suarez
is the Ultimate Fighter!
TATIANA: The journey makes you
a better person
if you use the obstacles
to make you better.
I'm from a place that says,
"We don't break."
I've overcome a lot,
and I'm never gonna stop
till I'm at the top.
-♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
-(CHEERING)
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪